the brain wants something new something
fresh it's boring to always go back to
the same source hi there steve kaufman
here and today i want to talk about the
importance of variety in language
learning remember if you enjoy these
videos please subscribe
click on the bell for notifications if
you follow me on a podcast service uh
please leave a review so today i have a
t-shirt on normally when i go to do
these videos even though i'm wearing a
t-shirt a grubby t-shirt for
doing tasks around the house or whatever
i'll put on a nice golf shirt or a
shirt with a collar for my video because
i feel that that's what i should do for
all my listeners out there
however
in fact that's not necessary and i
decided to change things up to sort of
symbolize the importance of changing
things up in your language learning
routine
variety is extremely important i've
mentioned this before i've said the
brain requires repetition
but it also requires novelty
and the reason i decided to do this
video is that i was listening to some
new material in persian
about the islamic revolution and the
history of the islamic revolution
in a podcast
and i started noticing certain words and
phrases that i hadn't noticed before
when they were in content that i was
used to listening to and it reminded me
of how important it is to vary things
vary the content you're listening to
uh vary the nature of the content in
other words easy content and more
difficult content
repeating
uh repetitively listening to things that
you know
tackling new material
all of this is important
and uh you know i've mentioned in a
previous video on interleaving that
that even though people
feel that they can learn something by
focusing in on it and studying it hard
cramming for the exam tomorrow in fact
research
uh on how the brain learns and a lot of
it done by professor bjork out of uh
california that it's when we
study a bit of this and go off and do
something else and come back later on
and go back to the first item that we
were studying that we learned better
whenever we block learn we try to focus
on one thing at a time in fact we are
learning less and less every time
if i focus back or think back on my
learning of
chinese or japanese
you know i used the sort of repetitive
listening
in order to get the rhythm of the
language and so in the case of chinese i
listened to these seongshan dialogues
comic dialogues even if i didn't fully
understand them
because the the rhythm the intonation of
the language sort of penetrated my brain
i found it very useful
in order to improve my pronunciation my
feel for the language there was also a
uh an audio version and of course in
those days it was a great big open reel
tape recorder on the history of the
second world war and i still remember
the arts of surgeon
the
that was like he was almost
sounded like he was talking too fast but
i picked up on the rhythm of that
uh phrase second world war
and many others
similarly when i was in japan
even though i was constantly reading new
material eventually reading the
newspapers reading different
books with with vocabulary lists
glossaries that i could find in the in
the bookstores in japan there was one
series that i listened to over and over
again even though i didn't fully
understand it and that was i've
mentioned this before
the sort of nhk series on showa no
kiroku the history of the showa era
and
part of it of course is that this audio
has to grab you at some level and i
enjoyed it i enjoyed
the
main narrator's voice and the excerpts
from history and i would listen to it
and it was all part of bringing that
music and that intonation of the
language into my brain so that was one
form of activity but i was also
challenging myself with new material
different material so always the sense
of variety
variety in terms of your activities
if you are a person who likes to do
flash cards fine i'm not a big flash
card as i've explained before
but spend some time on vocabulary spend
some time on grammar maybe if you're
interested
spend some time listening spend some
time reading
the greater variety you introduce into
your learning activity or speaking for
that matter obviously the speaking
depends on your opportunity to speak
more opportunities if you live where the
language is spoken but you can arrange
to speak online with the tutor
so variety have a deliberately a
deliberate program of introducing
variety that's one of the difficulties
in language learning at school typically
there's a textbook
and there they might even have a reader
with stories in it and you have that
textbook and the reader and that's all
you do
that's not very good because after a
while
the brain wants something new something
fresh it's boring to always go back to
the same source the same book the same
type of exercises
so if you are in charge of your own
learning or even if you're in a
classroom situation
try to introduce variety it'll help you
do better on the things that you're
forced to do in the classroom but it'll
because it's going to make sure that you
improve in the language so
i just wanted to to remind you of the
importance of
of variety even in terms of where you
study sometimes if you can be listening
outside or while jogging or
you know reading in different rooms in
the house and
the extent to which you introduce
variety it's all beneficial to your
learning
so i did a video on interleaving so i
would invite you to go and have a look
at that
and uh
i think you know one other relevant
video perhaps so that you can follow up
on this subject but remember
variety is the spice of life variety is
going to help you learn
and if you're in charge of your learning
you set the program you can change
things you can decide what you're going
to spend your time on
thank you for listening
bye for now